bienvenue à toutes et à tous dans ce
nouveau concept pourquoi sont ils si
unique depuis quelque temps j'étais à la
recherche d'un moyen de vous parler de
personnages marvel que j'adore 1 et tout
en mêlant à la fois le fait de vous
parler des comics le marvel cinématiques
l'universe base énormément là dessus
comme vous le savez et puis j'aime
l'idée de pouvoir retracer
historiquement la vie complète d'un
personnage il ya des personnages qui ont
même plus de 60 ans d'existence et qui
ont énormément évolué en fonction de la
vision des scénaristes ou encore des
dessinateurs à travers le temps et c'est
ce dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui
dans cette première vidéo nous allons
nous concentrer sur le personnage de
quang le conquérant kangs est
probablement mon vilain préféré de
l'univers marvel il possède une histoire
très complexe due à la question du
voyage dans le temps des nombreuses
réalités ou même tout simplement ses
nombreuses identités qui existe à
travers le temps et l'espace et cetera
voilà c'est une entité acquis j'aimerais
clairement rendre hommage cette vidéo
est un prototype une sorte d'épisode
pilote donc à vous de me faire un
maximum de retours afin de savoir si le
concept vous plaît s'il y a des éléments
sur lesquels je dois m'améliorer si
c'était cool à regarder et cetera et
cetera je compte sur vous c'est un
concept qui me tient quand même pas mal
à coeur bref ne tardons pas plus
longtemps il est temps de retracer
l'histoire de quang le conquérant et
vous montrer pourquoi ce dernier est si
unique que la vidéo commence
nous sommes le 9 juillet
1964 le comics avengers numéro 8 vient
de sortir et ce dernier nous introduit
un tout nouvel ennemi pour l'équipe de
super-héros qui marquera les fans durant
les presque 60 prochaines années il
s'agit bien évidemment de quang le
conquérant par le biais d'un vaisseau
atypique quand tu vas nous faire une
démonstration de puissance par le biais
de son armement et demande aux
dirigeants du monde de venir à sa
rencontre pour écouter ses
revendications les avengers seront
appelés en urgence pour résoudre ce
problème malheureusement kang est
différent des ennemis que les avengers
ont déjà pu affronter ce dernier possède
une technologie qui est encore
inconcevable pour l'humanité du 20e
siècle par le biais d'un seul bouton
présent sur son armure kang réussi à
neutraliser les avengers grâce à sa
maîtrise de lentilles gravité même tort
avec son marteau mjolnir ne pourra rien
faire ayant démontré sa force et sa
conviction auprès des plus grands héros
de la terre quand nous dévoile son
origin story et va nous faire des
révélations plutôt intéressante sur le
personnage l'autoproclamé le conquérant
nous explique qu'il est né dans le 31ème
siècle une époque où il a dompté le
voyage dans le temps grâce à ça il a pu
traverser les époques pour arriver dans
un lointain passé où il s'est érigé en
tant que pharaon sous le nom de rama
tout ensuite il nous est dit qu'il est
revenu dans le xxème siècle où cette
fois ci il a fait la rencontre du dr
doom après ces péripéties le
protagoniste souhaitait retourner dans
son époque le 31ème siècle mais à cause
d'une perturbation du flux temporel ce
dernier va finalement atterrir en l'an
4000 une époque de désolation où
l'humanité est constamment en guerre
avec elle même les humains de ce siècle
sont même qualifié de barbares et de
sauvage par rama tout sauf que qui dit
quarante et unième siècle
dit également avancées technologiques et
là c'est une aubaine pour le futur
conquérant ce dernier va réussir à
rallier énormément de personnes derrière
lui et va commencer à s'intéresser à
cette technologie qui est encore
inconnue en quelques semaines le
récemment devenue gang le conquérant va
établir un empire aux quarante et unième
siècle malheureusement cet empire est
basé sur un monde en train de mourir
donc kang va faire le choix de revenir
au 21ème siècle pour rebâtir son empire
dans une époque où le monde se porte
bien avec ce premier comics introduisant
kang il y a déjà des choses
intéressantes à dire sur le personnage
effectivement la révélation qu'avant de
devenir le conquérant il était un
pharaon du nom de rama tout n'est pas
anodine car exactement un an avant la
sortie d'avengers suite sortait le
comics fantastique fort 19 qui
introduisait l'antagoniste de rama tout
on nous y apprend plus en détail que
rama tout devenait du 31ème siècle une
époque qu'il haïssait car trop paisible
et était très intriguée par l'époque des
4 fantastiques
ce dernier est alors parti à la
recherche du laboratoire d'un de ses
ancêtres et ea a fait la découverte
d'une machine à voyager dans le temps
c'est là qu'il a appris à dompter les
voyages temporels le protagoniste a
fabriqué une machine en forme de sphinx
est parti en destination de l'egypte
antique devenu rama tout le pharaon a
croisé la route des quatre fantastiques
qui ont voyagé dans le temps pour
récupérer une fleur capable de rendre la
vue à alicia master's la petite amie de
la chose ces derniers se feront capturé
par le pharaon mais réussiront à se
libérer et défaire ram à tout qui n'aura
que pour seule issue de s'échapper via
sa machine temporelle presque un an plus
tard le 2 juillet 1964 soit sept jours
avant la sortie du comics avengers
numéro 8 nous retrouvons rama tout lors
de son escapade ce dernier va tomber sur
le dr doom en train de dériver dans
l'espace du à sa récente défaite face
aux quatre fantastiques
ram à tout va le ramener dans son
vaisseau et les deux protagonistes vont
avoir une discussion ou rama tout va
mentir sur ses origines révélant qu'il
viendrait du 25ème siècle et qu'il se
pourrait en fait que le dr doom soit son
ancêtre car le laboratoire où il a fait
la découverte de la machine à voyager
dans le temps était en fait celui du
docteur les deux antagonistes vont alors
penser qu'ils sont la même personne mais
venant de différentes temporalités et ce
sera que bien plus tard que nous aurons
les révélations à ce sujet ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'à l'époque mme
harvey semblait avoir un désir de relier
l'identité de ram à tout et de quang le
conquérant avec le docteur doom
finalement il va s'avérer que cette
relation sera beaucoup plus complexe que
ça en tout cas quand gars étaient
capables de devenir ce qu'il deviendra
tout simplement car hell est un génie de
son époque un brillant scientifique un
scientifique qui a maîtrisé la
technologie et le voyage dans le temps
et de part son règne en tant que rama
tout gang est quelqu'un qui sait diriger
et qui sait rassembler les troupes
derrière lui il est un leader puissant
et charismatique
c'est pourquoi il a dominé complètement
le quarante et unième siècle dans le
comics avengers huit camps qui se fera
finalement avoir par les avengers et un
groupe de militants qui n'accepte pas
que le conquérant devienne leur
souverain kang qui qualifiait les
avengers de primitifs car provenant
d'une époque passée lointaine sera
finalement piqué dans son ego le
conquérant s'est fait ridiculiser et a
dû s'enfuir ce dernier va réapparaître
dans le comics avengers 11 sortie le 8
octobre 1964 n'ayant pas digéré sa
défaite face aux avengers kong va créer
un robot à l'éffigie de spider man mais
cela va s'avérer une fois de plus un
échec mais à partir d'ici une nouvelle
page va s'écrire pour le conquérant car
le 12 octobre 1965 sort le comics
avengers numéro 23 dans ce dernier kang
va piéger une partie de l'équipe des
avengers et les envoyer dans un lointain
futur il va s'avérer que kang a capturé
les avengers dans le but d'impressionner
une jeune princesse du nom de ramona
dont le royaume est assiégée par les
troupes du conquérant kangs veut faire
de la princesse sa femme et menacent de
prendre le royaume si cette dernière
n'accepte pas sa requête bien évidemment
cette dernière refuse et ne sera en
aucun cas impressionné par la
démonstration de puissance de gang face
aux avengers de colère ayant mis en
garde ramona et son père le roi quang va
attaquer le royaume avec ses troupes et
triomphera non sans mal faisant de lui
le nouveau souverain et là c'est une
nouvelle phase est intéressant de kong
qui nous est dévoilé le conquérant dont
l'avis est symbolisée par la guerre et
la victoire très respecté par ses
troupes va exiger que ramona devienne sa
femme comme prix de sa victoire sur le
royaume sauf que ce n'est normalement
pas du tout dans les codes de kong le
conquérant ce dernier fait la guerre
conquiert et aucune pitié pour les
opposants en voulant épargné à vonnas et
en faire sa femme kang fait entorse à
ses propres règles et dévoile un nouveau
visage qui ne va pas du tout plaire à
ces soldats kong est en fait amoureux
désigné comme une faiblesse par balles
tag l'homme de main de gang ce dernier
va monter une mutinerie face à leurs
dirigeants et quang va devoir s'allier
aux avengers pour faire face à ses
propres troupes est sauvé ramona le
conquérant va finalement sauver le
royaume de sa propre armée
sauf que dans une erreur d'inattention
balle tag toujours en vie va tirer une
balle sur kang le conquérant et ramona
nous dévoilant qu'elle était en fait
elle aussi amoureuse du conquérant va
s'interposer et prendre la balle à la
place de kong ce qui la tuera
instantanément dans les bras du
protagoniste
qu'engrais apparaîtra dans le comics
thor 140 sortie le 2 mars 1967 où son
robot caché sur terre le stimule aux ide
sera découvert et causera un sacré bazar
gangs se dévoilera pour le récupérer et
fera face à tort avant de s'échapper ce
comics de thor va permettre d'introduire
le stimule aux ide pour la trilogie de
comics avengers 69 70 et 71 ou le
stimule aux ide sera en mission pour
kidnapper tony stark les avengers vont
bien évidemment s'y opposer et lors de
leur affrontement avec le stimule aux
ide seront téléporté dans le vaisseau de
quang le conquérant dans ce dernier nous
y retrouvons une rave ona en état de
stase dans une sorte de cloche en verre
kangs dont l'unique but a toujours été
de conquérir encore et toujours plus de
temporalité et de royaume a finalement
changé d'objectif pour ramener la femme
qu'il aime à la vie c'est alors que le
grand maître des galaxies fera son
apparition pour proposer un jeu à kong
lui permettant d'avoir le contrôle total
sur la vie et la mort un jeu vicieux ou
kang obligera les avengers à participer
finalement kang par le biais des
avengers fera une sorte de match nul est
le grand maître des galaxies lui donnera
alors le choix de maîtriser pendant un
court instant le pouvoir de la vie ou de
la mort et non les deux car ce dernier
n'a pas gagné sauf que kang et han cong
le conquérant imbu de lui même et
envenimé par la haine choisira le
pouvoir de la mort pour défaire les
avengers haut lieu du pouvoir de la vie
qui lui aurait permis de ramener ramona
et au final ce sera un cuisant échec
puisque les abeilles gers survivront
kangs aveuglé par la colère
a perdu une opportunité de ramener sa
bien aimée et restera seul avec ses
regrets quand il reviendra dans hull que
135 sorti en janvier 1971 afin d'annuler
l'existence futur de banner dans le but
d'éviter la formation des avengers bien
évidemment il échouera février 1973 dans
les comics marvel team up 9 10 et 11
dans une autre réalité un voyageur
temporel du nom de arrow va conduire
iron man et spider man vers le 23ème
siècle dans le but de les confronter
avec kang le conquérant qui a capturé
les autres avengers et les a enfermés
dans sa citadelle les avengers eux
sortiront victorieux de cette
confrontation et quang s'échappera à
nouveau nous arrivons maintenant au
chapitre de la madone céleste pour bien
vulgariser la chose la madone céleste
est en gros une femme qui est censé
donner naissance un jour un être qui va
devenir surpuissant forcément kangs êtes
intéressés par cette idée d'avoir une
descendance puissante qu'il peut
manipuler comme bon lui semble et du
coup ils kidnappent eural à scarlet
witch monteith et agata harkness
suspectant que l'une des trois et la
madone céleste pendant ce temps là dans
l'ombre
quelqu'un vient de se réveiller après
cinq mille ans de sommeil il s'agit de
rama tout sauf que ce n'est pas
exactement le même rama tout que celui
que nous connaissons ce dernier qu'on
croit être l'identité qui précède celle
de quang que nous avons connu dans le
comics fantastique fort 19 est en fait
un ram à tout qui a déjà vécu sa période
en tant que kong le conquérant ce qui
veut dire qu'il est un après kong après
s'être lassé de ses conquêtes et se
rendant compte que toutes ces guerres ne
lui apportaient finalement aucune
satisfaction le protagoniste alors âgé
de 60 ans a quitté le quarante et unième
siècle pour retourner en egypte antique
une époque qui considèrent comme plus
heureuse et il redeviendra rama tout il
a alors détruit sa sphère lui permettant
de voyager dans le temps et a repris son
règne qui cette fois ci serait fait dans
la compassion et leur respect de son
peuple sauf que il s'est rappelé un
moment précis de son passé qui va
commencer à le trouble et n'ayant plus
aucun moyen de voyager dans le temps ce
dernier va trouver une autre solution
pour revenir dans l'ère moderne alliant
magie et technologies rama taux de va
s'enfermer dans un tombeau pendant cinq
mille ans avant de revenir pour
affronter son lui du passé et l'empêcher
d'acquérir la madone céleste rama tout
est revenu car il s'est rappelé que
quand il était encore kang le conquérant
1 rama tout désigné comme celui du futur
est venue contrecarrer son plan
d'obtenir la madone celle est désormais
devenu un ram à tout qui a délaissé son
identité de quang le conquérant c'est
désormais à lui d'intervenir contre
celui du passé pour l'empêcher de nuire
et c'est un moment que j'adore car c'est
la révélation que nous sommes dans une
boucle kang possède un destin et un
destin dont il ne semble pas pouvoir
s'échapper suite à leur confrontation
quand gherram à tout atterriront dans
les limbes un endroit hors du temps et
de l'espace là bas kang fera la
rencontre d'un certain immo russe et
l'on fermera avec rama tout pour les
empêcher de le nuire toujours en quête
de la madone céleste quand va
apprivoiser les limbes et se former une
armée de non vivant il transportera les
avengers dans ce lieu hors du temps et
de l'espace pour terminer sa quête sauf
que tout ne se passera pas comme prévu
immo russe est en fait la dernière
incarnation de gang une identité qui
vient après ganges et après son retour
en tant que rama tout en tant que senior
des limbes et du temps y morte us en
fait elle est portée kong dans les
limbes et lui a laissé prendre le
contrôle de l'endroit avant de le faire
échouer être sûr de garder la madone
céleste soit métis en sécurité quand guy
va réussir à s'échapper via le flux
temporel mais ne sait pas quand fait
morte us est un lui du futur toujours
dans cette obstination de conquérir le
xxème siècle quand il reviendra dans le
numéro 141 à 143 des comics avengers
cette fois ci ce dernier ira dans le
19ème siècle afin d'établir sa citadelle
dans le but d'être le maître du xxème
siècle avant l'existence futur des
avengers avec lady morte us qui souhaite
de tout coeur contrecarrer les plans de
kong dont il a déjà connaissance les
avengers est rond dans le passé pour
affronter kong au 19e siècle le
conquérant aura beaucoup de mal à tenir
tête face à tort et dans un excès de
colère augmentera la puissance de son
armure au maximum qui va créer une
surcharge et le tuer est morte us va
alors nous dévoiler qui étant donné que
kong est mort ce dernier ne reviendra
jamais rama tout et par conséquent
jamais il ne deviendra immo russe du
coup la boucle est brisé et immo russe
disparaît affirmant que lui et ses
autres identités sont désormais libres
et voici comment se termine l'histoire
de ganges le conquérant
non vous y croyez au contraire c'est à
partir de là que tout devient palpitant
le 11 février 1986 soit près de 15 ans
plus tard kong va réapparaître et pas de
n'importe quelle manière nous faisons
face à troyes kong réunis qui viennent
de téléporter un camp gnalin ben dans le
but de le tuer le kang fraîchement
abattu était en fait le dernier gang
divergent due à la création de réalité
alternative effectivement il nous sera
révélé en fait que les nombreux voyages
de cambes conquérant à travers le temps
ont en fait donné naissance à une
multitude de gang qui par le biais de
aussi de leur voyage donne naissance à
d'autres gangs les trois kang qui se
sont réunis pour former le conseil des
gangs s'était donné pour mission de
détruire tous leurs homologues divergent
et contrôler les temporalités de chacun
sauf que bien évidemment gang
étant un but de lui même et souhaitant
être le seul à régner à travers le temps
et l'espace souhaitera piéger ses deux
autres homologues il va réussir à tuer
son premier confrères en lui faisant la
surprise que ramona est en vie après
cela il placera son corps dans un siège
et elle apportera les avengers dans les
limbes dans le but de faire une pierre
deux coups les avengers vont trouvé le
cadavre du gang piégé l'autre gang
arrivera au même moment et va penser que
les avengers ont tué son confrère ce qui
va déclencher une bataille lequang
manipulateur va alors interrompre le
combat et faire prisonnier tout le monde
y compris l'autre gang de là il va
dévoiler son origin story et nous faire
une énorme révélation
son histoire est exactement la même que
les autres gangs il va d'ailleurs nous
divulguer qu'un sauveur venant d'une
autre réalité étant son ancêtre a sauvé
le 31ème siècle et apporter l'époque
paisible qu'il a toujours hays et qu'il
a fait fuir vers le passé sauf que
l'histoire du gang manipulateur en fait
un point de divergence vous vous
souvenez du comics 142 tort eh bien il
est là le point de divergence au moment
de s'échapper après que thor est
pourchassé le stimule aux ide il a créé
un vortex avec mjolnir au moment où kang
était sur le point de s'échapper ce qui
a fait que son vaisseau s'est perdu dans
le flux temporel et l'a fait atterrir
dans les limbes de là il a fait face aux
cadavres dit morte us et a été témoin
d'une machine ou sur tous les écrans il
pouvait boire tous ses homologues
divergent à travers le temps et l'espace
en voyant ces lui du passé il a décidé
d'intervenir et de sauver ramona de sa
mort de là il s'est rendu compte qu'en
sauvant ramona qui devait normalement se
prendre la balle de balle tags et mourir
et bien étant donné qu'elle n'était plus
présentes pour faire barrage et sauver
son amant le gang de cette réalité a été
abattu par balles tag ayant pris
conscience de ce qu'il venait de faire
quand s'est alors mis en quête de tuer
tous les autres gangs afin de stopper la
propagation de nouvelles réalités et de
nouveaux kong qui pourrait être une
menace malheureusement pour lui toute
son histoire était en fait une
manipulation dit morte us qui s'est
jouée est servie de lui afin de le faire
pour suivre son destin immo russe est la
version évoluée de gang il est le maître
du temps et des limbes et son rôle et
que kang poursuivre la même histoire que
lui pour que dans le futur ils
deviennent immortels gang qui divergent
pour atterrir dans les limbes ce n'est
pas la faute de tort c'était une
manipulation dit morte us kang qui
découvrent la multitude de divergences
de lui même c'est tim hortons ramona qui
a décidé d'épauler kang après avoir
quitté son flux temporel c'est tim
hortons et dans une ultime manipulation
pour que kangs empruntent la route qu'il
doit suivre immo russe lui dévoilera que
son histoire et sa quête dans les limbes
lui a permis d'avoir un objet du nom de
psyché globe lui permettant de connaître
toutes les routes possibles que kang
peux t'emprunter dans un excès de colère
et d'humiliation kong va voler le psyché
globe dans le but de connaître toutes
les histoires possibles où ce dernier
peut éviter son futur où il devient team
lotus mais bien évidemment c'était
encore une fois une manipulation de son
lui du futur et le psyché globe va
rendre fou kang le conquérant
nous allons faire un bond dans le temps
tout simplement car cela va nous
permettre de mieux comprendre le
personnage de quang le conquérant ce
dernier réapparaîtra de multiples
reprises comme dans avengers 293 avec le
conseil cros times des kong ou encore
dans le comics 323 des 4 fantastiques où
il tentera encore de récupérer mantis la
madone céleste les comics infinity ward
avec magnus et adam warlock l'arc
termina tricks avec la présence d'alios
que vous connaissez bien la série loki
et cetera etc parlons désormais de la
guerre du destin avec avengers forever
là bas nous y retrouvons un gang âgées
de plus de 60 ans est très fatigué de
ses conquêtes ce dernier est en train de
remettre en question toute sa vie et sa
haine pour immortals nous apprenons par
le biais de son histoire qu'il est le
prime kong celui qui a été manipulée par
him ortiz dans les limbes et que
beaucoup d'histoires de gangs dans les
premiers comics était en fait celle de
variants lequang enquête de la madone
céleste c'était un variant le camp qui
s'est autodétruit face à tort c'était un
variant et cetera et cetera bref tout ce
qu'on a connus concernant kong avant
l'arc de son arrivée dans les limbes
sont des variants mais étant donné
qu'ils avaient la même histoire que les
autres gangs jusqu'au comics numéro 142
tort eh bien on n'était pas trop perdu
ce qui va être intéressant avec avengers
forever c'est la question du destin qui
dit de la vie de gang depuis la
naissance immo russe a en fait tracer
toute la vie de gangs dans le but qu'un
jour lui-même de vie immo russe et quang
en a désormais conscience et cela le
perturbe sauf que quelque chose
d'intrigant va arriver vous l'aurez
compris au fil de la vidéo mais kang et
dans un destin et une boucle dont il ne
peut s'échapper c'est à dire qu'au fil
du temps il va devenir rama tout puis
scarlett centurion dont on n'a pas parlé
car son existence est très courte et pas
si pertinente que ça puis il deviendra
kong le conquérant il redeviendra rama
tout est enfin île morte us sauf que
dans avengers forever dû à des
perturbations avec la fin des temps et
les timekeeper au moment où le prime
kong redevenu rama tout va accepter son
destin pour finalement devenir immortel
ce dernier va avoir une vision de son
futur dans le flux temporel où il se
verra en tant qu' morte us en train d'
obéir aux ordres des townshippers et de
là va naître une rage immensément
profonde chez le protagoniste gang dont
toute la vie a été dictée et guider
malgré lui paris morte us ayant
désormais l'espoir d'être enfin libre en
devenant son lui du futur fait la
découverte que son avenir est aussi
dicté par des êtres supérieurs y mord
tus étant l'identité finale de quang le
conquérant cela veut dire que du berceau
jusqu'à sa mort sa vie n'aura été qu'une
ligne droite vers ce que le destin a
voulu de lui rama tout kong y mort tu ce
peu importe il n'aura finalement jamais
été libre et ça il ne peut le permettre
grâce à la divergence de la fin des
temps rama tout va se rebeller et
décidera d'ignorer le futur où il
devient immortel et reviendra aux
quarante et unième siècle pour redevenir
kang le conquérant plus en forme et plus
en colère que jamais de là il va
commencer à s'intéresser en profondeur à
son identité futur hymne hortus dans le
but de l'anéantir il va faire la
découverte de la fin des temps du rôle
des time keeper ou encore de la vie
qu'on let die morte us pendant ce temps
là les avengers font face aux thèmes
keepers qui souhaitent élaguer plusieurs
réalités où l'humanité a des chances de
créer l'effondrement de l'univers une
confrontation va éclater et kong va
débarquer dans le combat alliés de
l'intelligence suprême cri pour
justement à nier les immortels et les
timekeeper est morte us va finalement se
rebeller face à ses maîtres et sera
exécutée instantanément dans le but
d'avoir un nouveau immo russe en tant
que disciples ces derniers vont tenter
d'accélérer pendant le combat le destin
de quang pour que ce dernier devienne y
mort tu ce grâce à sa volonté et son
désir immensément profond de se libérer
du destin quand on va résister de toutes
ses forces et repoussera la tentative
des townshippers avant de les tuer en
ayant résisté à la manipulation des
townshippers la volonté de kong a donné
naissance à un hymne au russe totalement
différent lui prouvant qu'il a aboli son
destin et que désormais immortels et
quang sont deux identités bien
distinctes ce jour là kang a signé la
plus grande victoire de toute sa vie
désormais libre il s'est téléporté et
est retourné à son époque
les comics avengers forever ont été pour
moi un arc très intéressant sur
l'histoire de kang même si ce dernier
est un antagoniste un conquérant
assoiffé de pouvoir on se rend compte
finalement que six kong est toujours en
train de faire la guerre ou de conquérir
d'autres temporalité ou d'autres
réalités c'est finalement parce qu'il
est en quête d'aventurés et de libre
arbitre gang a besoin de se sentir en
vie il a besoin de sentir que sa vie un
sens et un sens qu'il a lui même choisi
il n'y a rien de plus démoralisant que
de se dire que son existence est en fait
une ligne droite toute tracée par des
êtres supérieurs qui en ont décidé ainsi
et parce que ça doit être comme ça et
pas autrement les voyages temporels les
empires qu'il a bâti sont une
échappatoire pour kang pour se prouver
qu'il est quelqu'un quelqu'un qui a fait
quelque chose dans sa vie et qu'il a
marqué l'histoire quand il va découvrir
au final que tout ce qu'il a accompli
est en fait un chemin tracé par ea morte
us la vie de gangs ne sera plus la même
ramona sa bien aimée qu'il l'avait trahi
les avengers qui sont ses ennemis jurés
ne seront même plus une priorité à
partir de ce moment-là il cherchera par
tous les moyens d'échapper au destin qui
mord tus et par extension les timekeeper
lui ont imposées quand gay d'ailleurs
caractérise également par ses mauvais
choix tout le long de sa carrière il se
laissera emporter à de nombreuses
reprises par la colère ce qui le
conduira à avoir des regrets et même par
moments de cuisantes défaites
mais malgré cela quand finira toujours
par survivre et revenir et rebâtir
quelque chose quand vous êtes un être
imparfait guidé par him or tus à
plusieurs reprises immo retenu cela en
fait sauvé d'une mort certaine
et l'a toujours guidé à se reconstruire
car c'est le chemin qu'il devait prendre
donc en soi au final gang et puissant
car i morte us en a décidé ainsi
désormais libéré de cette boucle
infernale kang peut maintenant être
qu'il est véritablement et c'est
pourquoi c'est la plus grande victoire
de toute sa vie après cela nous
reverrons kong à de multiples reprises
et étant désormais une identité bien
distinctes de celles du maure tus kong
recommencera ses conquêtes est entre à
même d'influencer le passé dans le
comics young avengers il rendra visite à
son jeune lui afin d'accélérer le
processus qu'il fera qu'il va devenir
kang le conquérant car oui même si la
boucle est brisé kang aura toujours
similairement la même histoire mais une
histoire qui peut changer en fonction de
la volonté de chacun la preuve en est
son jeune lui horrifié par ce qu'il
deviendra va prendre l'identité d'un
super héros nommé ironclad pour défaire
son lui du futur néanmoins je préfère le
préciser quand même mais même malgré
tout ça kang reste quelqu'un de très
dangereux effectivement il est l'un des
plus grands scientifiques de son erp il
est l'un des plus gros cerveau de son
époque sans oublier que par le biais de
ses voyages temporels c'est comme s'il
avait vécu un million de vies il connaît
chaque époque il connaît de nombreuses
réalités et surtout c'est un seigneur de
la guerre sont passées en tant que rama
tout le pharaon d'égypte et même quand
il est devenu gang le conquérant aux
quarante et unième siècle ce sont des
éléments qui lui ont appris à diriger et
à fédérer les troupes derrière lui
d'ailleurs sa technologie est unique est
inconcevable c'est du jamais vu par
aucun autre protagoniste de l'univers à
part lui quand gay l'un des plus grands
ennemis des avengers et le restera
boucle du destin
ou pas et tout ça le rend unique
nous arrivons désormais à la fin de
cette vidéo je sais pas si vous l'avez
remarqué mais on n'a jamais prononcé une
seule fois le nom de nathaniel richard's
qui est le véritable nom de ganges le
conquérant il ya d'ailleurs plein de
moments des comics que nous avons ce qui
paie mais c'est tout simplement car je
voulais que l'on se concentre pleinement
sur l'identité de quang le conquérant
nous pourrions faire une vidéo complète
sur chacune de ces identités tellement
chacune possède une histoire
complètement inédite et complète mais
bon ce n'était pas le but aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs la vidéo commence à être bien
longue c'est pourquoi je me suis permis
de skip et certains passages car sinon
la vidéo ferait deux heures et au final
je trouve que cela aurait pas apporté
grand-chose de rajouter ces moments et
cela aurait pas expliqué forcément
pourquoi quand guy si unique d'après moi
en tout cas j'espère de tout coeur avoir
répondu à la question j'espère également
que la vidéo vous aura plu comme je le
disais c'est un concept que je tente
j'aimerais beaucoup le reproduire à
l'avenir pour d'autres personnages
iconiques de marvel donc voilà je compte
sur vous d'ailleurs pour me conseiller
certains personnages si vous aimeriez
que voilà on parle de certains
personnages n'hésitez pas comme ça je
verrai ce qui vous a le plus j'attends
sincèrement vos retours par rapport à
cette vidéo s'il ya des choses sur
lesquelles je dois m'améliorer si tout
simplement au final cela vous a plu car
on sort quand même du cadre des théories
pour rentrer dans celui des comics donc
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
voilà n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la
chaîne n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleus merci à tous ceux qui seront
restés jusqu'au bout que le lionheart
soit avec vous cet argot rock allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]